لأنها شعرت بأن الهواء يمتص
من المنزل ،
اعتقدت لانا أنها قنبلة ليس
لأنها صاخبة
، كما لو كانت قاسية ، لقد
كان مؤلمًا
كما لو أن بناتها سألتها للتو عما إذا
كان بإمكانهن الذهاب إلى مكان صديق.
كان صعودًا و زوي وليو مثل
الوقوف هنا حيث يمكننا رؤية الساعة
تمسك ببعضها البعض
وقت الصراخ وقفت ثابتة ، تخيلت
أنهما تم قطع رأسهما بعيدًا ،
كما لو
أنني حصلت عليهما هنا على الأرض
اعتقدت أنني قمت بسحب هذا
هذا أوه ، لا يزال هناك دم على
المرتبة ، نعم ،
هذا إذا حاولت تحريكها
حاول ألا
تسألني كيف كان هذا حرفيًا كما لو
كنت قد صنعته ،
لذلك كنت أقود السيارة فقط
للوصول إلى الأطفال  ولانا أندريه
لم يكن زوجها في
المنزل ، فركضت لرؤيتهم وأرى أن
كل شيء
سقط كان بسبب الفوضى وبدأت
أصرخ مع الأطفال مع الأطفال
وكان ظهر لانا ممزقًا ، وكان هناك
جرح هائل في
فخذها.  أوه ليس لديك  إنه مثل
الخدوش
والآخر يشبه تمامًا
أنها
تعاني من اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة كما نقول مثل
سؤالها أخبرتني أن الأمر سيحدث
مرة
أخرى وقلت لها لا ، وأعدك بأنها
لا تستطيع أن تجعلني هذا الوعد ليا
سألت إذا كانت  يمكنها الزحف مرة أخرى إلى بطنها
، كما أخبرت والدتها أن ثور
كان سيوقف الانفجار
بمطرقته هل تعتقد أن الأم بطلة
لا أحد يعرف كيف يشرح ذلك
لأنفسهم ، ولا يهم
أطفالهم الجنون المطلق  إنها المذبحة مشاهد
الفوضى
التي لا يستطيعون الهروب منها متأصلة
في نفسهم
وتهدد بدفعهم فوق الهاوية
إلى الهستيريا ،
ما زلت غاضبًا جدًا لفهم
ما حدث لماذا
كل هؤلاء الناس
[موسيقى
] ويحبون في رأسي مثل الليل  إنها تساوي
التدبيس في المستشفى
وليلة الدم هي الدم
الذي يحتجزون به أطفالنا
كرهائن جسديًا وعقليًا
، إنه هذا الأمر الذي لا يمكنني الذهاب إلى
أي
مكان لم تعجبه الأصوات بعد الآن.
قبل التزمير ، أبلغ من العمر 36 عامًا ، أشعر
بالرعب في كل مرة
وكأنها في السابعة من عمرها ، لم يرغبوا في النوم
هنا ،
فهم لا يشعرون بالأمان في غرفة والديهم
، لقد أخذوا هذا بعيدًا
عن العديد من الأطفال ، وليس فقط
أطفالي  ذهب الأطفال بعد ستة أشهر من رسم
أقواس قزح وحوريات البحر بعد
ثلاثة أشهر ، سألوني
كل يوم ما هو الكورونا
داستول اليوم في بيروت.
احتراق
اروى دامون CNN بيروت